but it can get tiring especially when
like you know
you have to deal with being judged
constantly
it's not as simple as like i'm gonna
make a thing and it's fun you know we
[__] live in a world where people
like well i think you think [__]
sucks how about that you're like well
thanks i am not that way i'm not built
that way you'll never know what i don't
like um you'll never hear me [__]
crying about like this movie [__]
suck i'll spend my entire time telling
you about things i do like but you'll
never hear about the [__] that bugs me
why life is too short to waste time
bitching and
i love the internet and have forever man
i've profited from it greatly i've been
on the net since like 1995 is when we
put up the viewski website but lately
it's
[__] horrible hellscape were there
just some people who just wake up
and [__]
like everything they [__] put out
there in the world is negative
everything is just like this sucks
you're bad these [__] are doing this
when are we gonna like [__] aren't
happy it's crazy they gave the world
this communication device where you
could do anything you can express
anything you want you can be funny like
[__] on tick tocks like like that
[__] who like does all the ikea
tick tocks with the mustache he's
[__] hysterical
or he could be the person that wakes up
every day and it's just like
they're wrong and we're right
like there's some [__] man that
like wind up in my timeline i don't even
follow them but some of the
[__] post them because they're
like look at this [__] and they're
every [__] tweet
is so some dire [__] negative
horrible thing some offense that they're
[__] feeling and a single tweet like
had coffee it was great
you know just so [__] shitty and
[__] negative and stuff that stuff
gets tiring i think that's because
you've got to [__]
circumnavigate all that crap i think you
attract it you know have you by being
positive which sucks like you would
imagine i always try to tell the
negative people it's just like you're
doing it [__] wrong like if you hate
my guts
don't sit around bitching about how much
i suck use that as fuel to do the thing
you need to do because if i suck and
you're superior to me
clearly
you can do what i do
i should be encouraging to you not a
[__] like somebody you bash i should
be your [__] lodestar cause you're
like if this [__] backwards chimp has
a career
then clearly there's going to be a place
for me at the table but instead people
are content to just sit there and be
like oh [__] him and [__] this and [__]
those people it's such a tremendous
waste of their time and energy like the
amount of time you sit around telling a
[__] how much you hate [__] and
how this needs to be [__] and this
needs to be fixed it's time you could be
creating something creating something of
your own that fosters a [__] living
i make a living out of being positive
[__] i know there are some
people make a living out of being
negative but they're a bunch of
[__] who just be negative for
[__] free and it's like you're doing
it wrong [__] like this is a complete
waste of your time do you want to be me
cause that's what i'm reading behind the
lines here you don't understand why i'm
doing what i do but you're not the
difference is i'm not wasting my time
like you bitching about why i don't got
what i want and i'll tell you there are
things that i would like in this life
that i don't have but you'll never
[__] hear about them because why what
a waste of [__] time that would be to
tell you what i don't have when you
could clearly look at me and be like and
yet you have too much you have so much
but isn't it it's a huge first of all
lovely i'm gonna put sometimes we go
real pete sometimes it's not just
one just jokes
just one just one it's not just
periodontal jokes sometimes it's no it's
great and obviously mark the time
because that's fantastic but mark the
time well we put a little bit of cut out
we're gonna take it out and any mention
of smodcaster the joe rogan experience
because we're trying to we're trying to
get
your balls over here
[Music]